russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
has said his country appreciates india
for not taking a quote one-sided view of
the situation in ukraine lavrov is in
india hoping to shore up a time-tested
partnership in the midst of crippling
economic sanctions over the war in
ukraine
this is what he said at a meeting with
indian foreign minister s joshankar
our western colleagues would like to
reduce any meaningful
international issue to the crisis in
ukraine
uh you know our position
we
do not hide
anything and we appreciate that india is
taking this situation in
the
entirety of facts not just
in a one-sided way
and earlier in the day indian foreign
minister s jaishankar met sergey lavrov
in delhi that's a tweet from sj
shankar's twitter account india's heavy
reliance on russian arms imports for its
military has forced india to abstain
from u.n resolutions censuring russia
both countries are also exploring a
currency mechanism that would allow
india to purchase cheaper crude oil from
russia sidestepping western sanctions
and earlier today foreign minister
lavrov said russia is willing to use the
indian rupee for international trade
amongst the indian public itself there
appears to be a lot of support for the
country's position on russia here's a
sample of the mood on the streets of
delhi
because we have a lot to gain from this
you know because uh
see like when you see that we are now
directly buying the oil from russia we
couldn't do that earlier like you know
and we can now do that
and we have a long-standing trade
relation like we know we buy our
military aircrafts and all from russia
we have this brahmos missile joint
venture with russia so i think
it's pretty good thing that like you
know that we are pretty vocal about our
support for russia now india's stand is
absolutely fine because they are
standing up for themselves which we
should be doing
and let's get more on this from garema
mohan she's a fellow at the asia program
at the think tank the german martial
fund garuma to quote u.s president joe
biden india is being seen as court
somewhat shaky on russia help us
understand where india stands right now
so india is
in a bit of a difficult position because
it has a long-standing partnership with
russia but one has to understand that
the nature of the india-russia
partnership has changed significantly
india's position right now of a study
neutrality does not mean that it
supports russian actions it just has a
different approach as to what to do to
solve the the current problem uh so
india had to take a more nuanced
position on this question because of
the location of indian students in
ukraine that needed to be evacuated 20
000 um indian students who were there
india's dependence on russia for
military equipment and technology which
a lot of other countries have not agreed
to
do in the past and russia has provided
certain equipment to india given the
crisis it faces with china on the border
which flared up in 2020 and hasn't
really gone away
this is playing a very important role in
india's calculus in the long term
however india's approach is that
isolating russia will probably not be
helpful it wants to
preserve whatever remnants of a leverage
it still has with moscow so russia does
not reach the conclusion that china is
its only partner in the world and india
wants to be able to retain the leverage
to to influence what's going on i have
to say that um it has been clear made
clear to us that in private india has
strongly criticized uh russia's actions
and even with the with the lavrov visit
today we saw some of that uh you you
talked about uh china a little while
earlier and
the partnership between russia and china
has been defined as a no limits
partnership by the leaders of both
nations uh how does that figure into new
delhi's view on ties with moscow
that is exactly uh the reason why new
delhi is so concerned
because
the main the key factor for india is the
threat from china and in case that this
gets worse
um india does not want russia to play
spoiler um inside with china and india
wants russia to play a somewhat uh
constructive role so this is of course
playing into india's calculations but
some have also noted that the
russia-china partnership is perhaps a
little bit overblown currently uh that
this is not an alliance and russia would
not want to be a junior partner to china
uh but of course india is watching this
development very closely and it is it is
worrying for for indian policy makers
right now
and uh of course uh garima delhi has
also faced a lot of criticism over its
plans to buy cheap russian crude oil in
the wake of the ukraine invasion and i'd
just like to play for our viewers an
exchange between visiting uk foreign
secretary lee struss and indian foreign
minister s joshankar last evening in
delhi let's just have a quick listen
ultimately it's oil and gas that is
funding putin's war machine and we need
to
cut off reliance on that and we need a
timetable to end reliance on russian oil
and gas so we need to do more and we
can't be complacent
now i was just reading a report today
that in the month of march europe has
bought i think 15 percent more oil and
gas
from russia than it did the month before
if you look at the major
buyers of oil and gas from russia
i think you'll find most of them are in
europe
very much just listening to that
exchange i suppose the main question
really is if india is right to purchase
oil from russia now given that it's
clear that this money will be used and
has been used to fund russian aggression
in ukraine
so i think another point that the indian
foreign minister made yesterday
in this exchange that you played perhaps
explains a little bit more the indian
position he said that india continues to
buy majority of its oil from the middle
east
seven to eight percent from the united
states and only about one percent from
russia
so i think for the for the indian
government which is you know the
countries just coming out of the
devastating um delta wave and the impact
of the kovit 19 pandemic is being keenly
felt uh by citizens by consumers oil
prices are sky high um for the
government of course it has to balance
both of these concerns but i think a
point that minister jay shankar is
trying to make is that this isn't
perhaps the strongest uh point to to
hold india to account to given that a
lot of europeans are also you know
continuing to buy this and um foreign
secretary trust made the point that this
is a long-term thing countries will have
to reduce dependence on actors like
russia and perhaps also china but this
doesn't happen overnight it's you know
it has to be a long-term thing
but despite that india is coming in for
a fair bit of criticism particularly
from its uh western partners on its uh
let's call it continued fence sitting
when it comes to uh
in india's position on russia is india
concerned that this might affect its
relations with its western partners
moving forward
don't think that india is actually
coming under criticism if you look at
the statements that
we saw from visiting foreign dignitaries
in the last week we had the uk foreign
secretary we had the foreign security
policy advisor to the german chancellor
mr plotner visit india his counterparts
counterpart from the netherlands visit
india and what i found interesting in
all of their statements was that
they said that would we like india to be
in our camp yes but we understand the
position that india is taking currently
and to quote mr plotner he even said
that india is in a particular
geopolitical situation itself
it has challenges it is facing in its
neighborhood and therefore we understand
the calculus that india has made i think
one thing india has done is that it has
made clear to partners in the west why
it is taking the position that it is
that it is choosing to publicly not call
out russia but it does not support
russian actions and even though it has
abstained in u.n votes it has issued
public statements explaining its
problems with the you know with the war
and the the the path that russia has
chosen to take even today with the
meetings after foreign minister lavrov
the indian foreign minister announced
that
any conflicts should be solved through
diplomacy dialogue respecting the u.n
charter international law sovereignty
and territorial integrity of all
countries now this is the strongest
statement you would get from from india
strongest official statement condemning
the war that you would get from from
india
uh if i can just get you to look into
your crystal ball uh gary ma and briefly
at that do you think moving forward
india uh will continue to remain neutral
as it were with regard to russia or is
that position likely to change
i think if we look at indian foreign
policy
post-cold war from the 50s onwards
it has always taken the position of not
publicly criticizing countries but
expressing its anger privately it
believes that isolating countries does
not leave room for change as a country
that had sanctions imposed on itself it
also has a different view of sanctions
so i think we have to be a bit careful
in characterizing the indian position
as fence sitting or neutral but
as we see particularly the russia china
relationship develop further um and
india
if it if it sees that it is not you know
um it is losing a bit of its leverage
with moscow of course india will have to
go back to the drawing board and and uh
you know rethink uh the decisions that
it is making
karima mohan from the german marshall
fund uh always a pleasure talking to you
thank you so much for joining us today
thank you
thank you for having me
you